Beards, braids, and blood – transforming
into a viking isn't easy. Except for one
actress who was pretty much born for the part.
Find out who, and so much more right here!
Australian actor Sam Corlett portrays
the legendary explorer Leif Erikson,
the Norseman who is thought to have been the
first European to have set foot in North America,
centuries before Christopher Columbus. In
a promotional packet provided to the press,
Netflix describes the Erikson of
"Vikings: Valhalla," saying,
"[He’s] a Greenlander raised on the outer
fringes of the known world, [who] comes from
a tightly-knit family steeped in pagan beliefs."
It goes on to say that although Leif is an
intrepid sailor and physically tough, he is
also thoughtful and often quiet, and apparently
relatively new to the Viking world — which is
in the, quote, “throes of violent change.”
When Corlett was a teenager, he actually
watched the original "Vikings" with his father,
so it's fitting that he would go on to star in its
spinoff. The real-life Corlett still has the long
hair and facial hair of his Viking counterpart,
but keeps it much more neatly trimmed and styled
than Erikson. On set, Corlett -- who is vegan --
was costumed in vegan leather armor to honor his
personal convictions. This is another distinct
difference between the actor and the character
he'll be portraying.
[Yelling]
One of the most beloved characters on
"Vikings" was the shieldmaiden Lagertha,
played by Katheryn Winnick. So viewers are likely
eager to see another female Viking warrior rise up
in the "Valhalla" character Freydis Eriksdotter.
Netflix's description for Frida reads,
"Fiery and headstrong, Freydis is
a staunch believer in the old gods
and a fierce pagan. Like her brother Leif, she
reaches Kattegat as an outsider but becomes
an inspiration to those of the old ways."
Freydis will be portrayed by Swedish model
Frida Gustavsson, who has had an impressive
career walking in shows for some of the world's
most celebrated designers. As one might expect of
someone with Gustavsson's professional background,
her real-life look is much more polished than
the armored and intricately braided Freydis.
In what feels like a cosmic coincidence,
Gustavsson's real-life nickname is also
"Freydis," and her actual father and
brother are also named Erik and Leif,
just like those of her character in the show.
"Vikings" viewers will remember King Harald,
played by Peter Franzén, who appeared in seasons
four through six of the series as a leader
determined to be crowned king of all Norway.
"Vikings: Valhalla" will follow one
of his descendants, Harald Sigurdsson,
who carries the same ambition as his
ancestor. His Netflix bio reads,
"Born into Viking nobility, Harald is one of the
last Viking berserkers and a Prince of Norway
intent on becoming King of Norway. Charismatic,
ambitious, and handsome, he is able to unite both
Christian and pagan Vikings."
“Keep an eye on him.”
Harald will be portrayed by English actor
Leo Suter, who bears very little resemblance
to his Viking character. While Harald sports the
typical Viking look of a full beard and long hair,
Suter typically tends to prefer going clean-shaven
and keeping his hair cropped fairly short.
Some actors need to undergo greater
transformations than others for their
roles in "Vikings: Valhalla," and actor Bradley
Freegard may be one of the least altered for
his role as King Canute, the King of Denmark. The
Netflix press materials describe Canute, saying,
"A wise, savvy, and ruthless Viking leader.
He keeps his friends close and his enemies
closer. Canute's ambitions will mold the
course of history in the 11th century and
make him a defining figure of the Viking Age."
In real life, Welsh actor Freegard doesn't look
too remarkably different from his character. Both
have dark hair and full beards, although Canute
keeps his black hair long and tightly pulled back,
while Freegard wears his cut short and allows some
of the natural gray to peek through. Freegard also
keeps his beard trimmed to a much shorter length
than Canute's. Canute's family play a central role
in "Vikings: Valhalla," with his wife and father
also vying for power as Canute works to make sure
Denmark remains on top of the political hierarchy.
It wouldn't be a "Vikings" story without
feuding siblings, and "Valhalla" promises
that in spades. Icelandic actor Jóhannes
Haukur Jóhannesson portrays Olaf Haraldsson,
Sigurdsson's older half-brother and Prince
of Norway. Olaf is first in line for the
Norwegian throne, which we imagine will be a
point of contention between him and Harald.
Olaf's Netflix bio reads,
"Ambitious, unforgiving,
and a physical force to be reckoned with, Olaf
is also an extremely devout Christian Viking."
"Vikings" viewers will remember that the former
priest Athelstan was the first practicing
Christian to live among the Vikings, although
the conflict between his beliefs and those of
his Viking neighbors ultimately led to his
death. It will be interesting to see how
those dynamics have shifted over a century later.
In real life, Jóhannesson has kept the long, full
beard of his character, but not his long hair,
preferring instead a style that is cut close on
the sides and slightly longer on top. In addition
to being one of the main cast members of "Vikings:
Valhalla," Jóhannes Haukur Jóhannesson is also an
accomplished chef. The Netflix press kit mentions
that he was frequently known to bring in homemade
baked goods for the stunt crew during rehearsals.
Of the Viking leader Jarl Haakon,
Netflix's press packet reads,
"A great warrior and tolerant leader,
Haakon rules Kattegat with a steady hand.
Though pagan, she has managed to keep Kattegat
a city open to all faiths in a challenging time.
She will become a powerful mentor to
Freydis, who is drawn to her wisdom."
Of course, we know from watching Ragnar's
struggles in "Vikings" just how difficult
it can be to maintain peace between people of
different faiths in Kattegat. So it will be
interesting to see how Jarl Haakon manages to pull
that off -- if such a thing is even possible.
“I want to be reunited with my Christian friend.”
Jarl Haakon will be played by Danish-Swedish
singer Caroline Henderson, who is known primarily
for her more recent jazz albums after previously
singing mostly pop. Jarl Haakon is one of very few
Viking women we've seen in promotional materials
who seems to wear her hair loose more often
than not. So, her normal appearance is not
quite as drastic of a shift from her
Viking look as some of her castmates.
"Valhalla" will feature the family of one
of Alfred, King of Wessex’s descendants:
King Aethelred II, and Aethelred's wife,
Emma of Normandy. This is what the
Netflix press packet has to say of Emma:
"The young, ambitious Emma of Normandy is from
the Norman court in France, and of Viking blood.
She is now married to King Aethelred II, the
current King of England. Politically astute
and one of the wealthiest women in Europe,
Queen Emma is a sharp and capable leader."
Emma seems to follow in a long tradition of
shrewd queens on "Vikings," and is portrayed
by German actor and model Laura Berlin. On
"Valhalla," Emma's hair is a dark brown,
but in real life, Berlin's hair color has run
the full spectrum of colors, from dark to light,
and even a vibrant purple at one point. Berlin
has worked as a model since she was a teenager,
making her no stranger to the intricate
costumes she needs to wear as Emma.
Described in Netflix's press
materials for "Vikings: Valhalla" as,
quote, "the ultimate survivor," David
Oakes' character, the Earl of Godwin,
serves as chief counselor to the
King of England, Aethelred II.
Of Godwin's character, the description reads:
"Godwin was born on the political fringes and
is haunted by his late father's mistakes. Cunning
and savvy, he knows how to make powerful allies."
Godwin's portrayer is English actor David
Oakes, who is no stranger to historical dramas
thanks to his work on shows such as "The
Borgias," "The White Queen," and "Victoria."
"Vikings" introduced us to the complicated
world of English royal succession,
and "Vikings: Valhalla" continues that theme
with Prince Edmund, played by English actor
Louis Davison. His official Netflix bio reads,
"King Aethelred II's son with his first deceased
wife and now Emma of Normandy's stepson, Edmund
is first in line to inherit the English throne.
Edmund is nervous to lead, but will play a
vital role in deciding England's future."
Davison is still a relative
newcomer to the world of television,
only appearing in a few roles before
landing his part on "Vikings: Valhalla."
In real life, Davison's hair is much lighter
than Edmund's dark color, and although it is
still not long, he tends to wear it much
more loosely than Edmund's severe style.
Season 4 of "Vikings" introduced us to Aethelred,
the legitimate son of King Aethelwulf and his wife
Judith. Unfortunately for Aethelred,
Judith liked her younger son more,
and poisoned Aethelred rather than allowing him
to assume the throne. "Vikings: Valhalla" picks
up a few generations down this dysfunctional
family lineage, with Alfred's descendant
Aethelred II now on the English throne.
Portraying Aethelred II on "Vikings:
Valhalla" is veteran Irish actor Bosco Hogan.
He previously appeared in Season 5 of the
original "Vikings" series as the Lord Abbot at the
Lindisfarne monastery in the episode "Full Moon."
Hogan's look for "Valhalla" won't be tremendously
different from his real-life appearance,
with the addition only of a trim gray
beard — and, of course, a royal wardrobe.
It wouldn't be a "Vikings" show
without some religious extremism,
and in "Valhalla," it seems that box will
be checked by Jarl Kåre, played by Danish
actor Asbjørn Nissen. His Netflix bio reads,
"A mysterious and chilling figure, Jarl Kåre
is a murderous Christian zealot who presents
a very real threat to the old pagan ways."
This sounds almost as though Jarl Kåre will act
as a kind of reverse spiritual successor to Floki,
played by Gustaf Skarsgård. After all,
he was the devout "Vikings" character
whose spiritual convictions led him
to eventually murder Athelstan.
In real life, Nissen still has the
bald head and long, thick beard
that Jarl Kåre sports in "Valhalla," although it
looks like he takes much better care of
his beard than his Viking counterpart.
Concerning Queen Aelfgifu, played by Pollyanna
McIntosh, Netflix's press packet reads,
"She uses her charm and guile to great effect as
she promotes the interests of her Mercian homeland
and tries to assert herself in her husband
King Canute's growing power structure."
The Scottish actress takes on the role of the
formidable Queen Aelfgifu with a look on the
show seeing her donning elaborate blonde tresses.
This is a big step away from McIntosh's look in
real life. Although the actor has indeed been
blonde before, she is currently a brunette and
has recently been keeping her hair cut extremely
short for her role as Jadis in "The Walking Dead"
and "The Walking Dead: World Beyond."
“You’ll be answering to me.”
The final member of the main "Vikings:
Valhalla" cast is Danish actor
Søren Pilmark. He plays King Sweyn Forkbeard, who
Netflix describes in their press materials as,
"King Canute's father, who is
far less diplomatic than his son.
He will do whatever it takes to
protect his family's place of power,
and has no tolerance for traitors or
those who question his authority."
Of course, when it comes to "Vikings," we have
a feeling that "less diplomatic" tends to mean
"ruthless and violent." So it will be interesting
to see how far the Danish king is willing to
go in his quest to hold onto his power.
In "Vikings: Valhalla," Pilmark is nearly
unrecognizable as King Sweyn Forkbeard,
whose graying hair is long and wild,
looking as though he's forgotten to comb it since,
well, ever. Contrasted to Pilmark's real-life
appearance, in which the actor is typically
clean-shaven and short-haired, Pilmark's role
may be one of the most dramatic transformations
among the cast of "Vikings: Valhalla.”
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.